I think that everything that we live
with has a clear purpose and everything
and design is a virus for me so it sort
of infects everything that you do in a
positive way my name is Josh Owen I'm
chair of the industrial design program
and an associate at the Vignelli Center
for design studies here at RIT I've
always felt that products should speak
for themselves and I know there's irony
and the fact that I'm you know I behave
as a designer author yet I prefer to see
objects you know speak for themselves I
don't think that they need to be dressed
up by a designer name or by a brand I
don't feel that that my authorship
should change the way people perceive of
the object whether that's the espresso
machine or one of my objects I think
they should all speak clearly and
honestly from their formal attributes
without the need of brand identity a
good object can be like a paperclip you
know just kind of perfect and it's an
inception and almost invisible in the
landscape of things at the same time
that paperclip is a unbelievable story
of heroics and manufacturing and
technology and that's the way I'd like
to see many of my objects was fitting
into that kind of a context I test the
things that I design by living with them
by using them by experiencing them by
passing them along that is all very
important to me in in the role that I
play as an educator as a human being
many of the objects in the house or
objects I designed everything that we
live with has a story from the hardware
to the software to the
the structure every element here is its
own book it's very real to me and those
stories are very important to tell to my
children to tell to others to experience
to drink in the richness of life people
have come into the spaces that my wife
and I have lived in and said there's no
art on the walls and we say but the
walls are art you know the objects are
art everything's got a story I do aspire
to make things which have an iconic
sensibility so that maybe when people
make decisions about them they're
thinking this is something that all I'll
pass along with something which
functionally speaking won't go bad